smoke rises in the aftermath of an
airstrike on pasigi Village in Northern
Myanmar more than a hundred people had
gathered for the opening of an
administration building including many
women and children
the Junta and napador sees buildings
like this as legitimate military targets
as it tries to tighten its hold on the
country two years after seizing power
at 7 45 in the morning fighter jets
attacked they were followed by mi-35
helicopter gunships
the initial death toll hard to gauge
many of the bodies disfigured in the
attack and rescue efforts hampered when
the gunships returned
we had to stop rescuing people in
retrieving bodies as they came back with
the helicopter at around 1pm and
attacked again three rescue workers died
in the attack
now that the helicopter is gone we are
resuming retrieving the bodies the
attack seems to be one of the worst
since the military coup of 2021 and an
indication that myanmar's military sees
little difference between military and
civilian targets
we strongly content this kind of
atrocities by the military and against
the civilians we call that this
constitute is to work right by the
military because it's a violation of the
Geneva Convention targeting the
civilians and it's a part of the
military strategies to attack on the
communities of the people at the Armed
Forces Day Parade last month the
military highlighted its air Power Jets
and helicopters have been used
increasingly to attack militias
resisting military rule around the
country
but the generals who command them seem
unconcerned by the civilians being
caught in the crossfire Tony Chang Al
Jazeera Bangkok